all right are people who don't people the
people who don't keep the sabbath will they
make it to heaven people
who disobey god will be lost
are you with me people who willfully deliberately
fragrantly directly high-handedly disobey god will
be lost because if god saves them sin will
start all over again so when the person says
well those who don't keep the sabbath to be lost
martin luther didn't keep the sabbath eloy said
he'd be in the kingdom william miller didn't keep
the sabbath he was not convicted he'll be in the
kingdom during the dark ages there were thousands
and millions who knew nothing about the sabbath
because it was an age of darkness but god
knew the heart of those people they'd be saved
but when in 1844 october 22 the temple was opened
then the light of the lord flashed out all over
the world so that excuse is gone are you with me
blessed are they that do his commandments that
they may have right this is not salvation by works
this is expressing your love through obedience
you